as more countries ease coronavirus
restrictions many students around the
world are returning to classrooms in
Europe early reports suggests that
sending kids back to school has not led
to a significant increase in infections
but there are still concerns over how to
keep children safe with the number of
reported cases globally now above five
million Holly Williams reports on what
different nations are doing they're
disinfecting classrooms in South Korea
keeping a safe distance apart in France
practicing their hand-washing in Denmark
and having their temperature checked in
Belgium
as children begin heading back to school
around the globe the new normal comes
with lots of new rules it won't be the
same said ten year old Clara in France
we can't give hugs anymore but at least
it can help stop the virus the reopening
of schools in 22 European countries has
reportedly not caused a spike in
infections though some have only been
open for just over two weeks at this
school in Belgium they've replaced the
school bell with the theme from Star
Wars an attempt to inject some fun at a
stressful time for many parents they're
still worried though it's coupled with
relief more than 1.5 billion students
have had their schooling interrupted
according to the UN and while some have
the resources to learn at home others
are missing out entirely on weeks or
even months of education Danish
elementary schools were the first to
reopen in Europe last month but some
parents claim their young children were
being used as guinea pigs and argued
older students should have gone back
first the country's Education Minister
told CBS News it was a tough decision
the small children has more difficulties
with the distance learning than the
older children and therefore we started
out with the young children Taiwan is
already an old hand
new normal it only closed at schools for
two weeks in February at dodge our
elementary school the children disinfect
on the way in and before every class
masks are compulsory they eat lunch
behind desk dividers and even learn how
to correctly measure social distancing
in math class no no wait out junk huh
it's all a bit of a hassle this group of
12 year olds told us they want things to
go back to how they were school may
never be exactly the same as it was but
for children around the world the first
step back to normality is getting back
to the classroom more than 230 children
in Europe have reportedly been affected
by the inflammatory syndrome that's also
sickened around 250 youngsters in the US
and that appears to be linked to the new
coronavirus the World Health
Organization has warned medics to be on
alert for signs of the the rare
condition Anthony
Holly Williams in Istanbul so many
different solutions to this problem
right now but great to see kids getting
back to school and I wish they replaced
the bell in my school with a star
wars-themed that's pretty cool thanks
Holly